imaginemos que tenemos una molécula de
oxígeno que primero tiene que entrar por
la boca o quizá también puede entrar por
la nariz de cualquier manera se
incorporara y bajará por la tráquea y de
ahí puede irse al pulmón izquierdo o al
pulmón derecho imaginemos que estamos
frente a esta persona a la izquierda
tenemos un pulmón grande con una pequeña
muestra cardíaca para el corazón a la
derecha está el otro pulmón y este no
tiene una muesca para el corazón porque
está al otro lado lo que quiero hacer
aquí es ver con detalle a este pequeño
alvéolo porque sabemos que tenemos
millones de estos alveolos en los
pulmones y es ahí donde sucede todo el
intercambio de gases pero necesitamos
saber exactamente lo que sucede tenemos
que acercarnos para ver los detalles
vamos a concentrarnos aquí entre los
alveolos que es la última parte del
árbol bronquial y el vaso sanguíneo de
hecho voy a acelerar esto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aquí están todas las capas entre los
alveolos y el capilar impresionante
cierto ahora tenemos esta molécula de
oxígeno estoy dibujando un círculo a su
alrededor va a encontrar su camino para
salir del alvéolo y primero tendrá que
pasar a la fase líquida esto es algo
importante entrará en esta delgada capa
de fluido que cubre el interior del
alvéolo y luego la célula de oxígeno va
a atravesar las células epiteliales la
molécula de oxígeno va a atravesar las
células epiteliales que forman las
paredes del alvéolo son estas células
planas con forma de panqueque y va a
llegar a la membrana basal recordemos
que esta membrana basal es una especie
de cimiento que ofrece mucho soporte
estructural a los pulmones y debajo de
ella está esta capa de tejido conectivo
que la molécula de oxígeno tiene que
atravesar pasa por otra capa de membrana
basal y luego baja a las células
endoteliales éstas también tienen forma
de panqueque y forman las paredes del
capilar a partir de ahí la molécula de
oxígeno va al plasma y luego finalmente
entra
glóbulo rojo y por supuesto los glóbulos
rojos están llenos de hemoglobina esta
es una pequeña proteína de hemoglobina y
esta hemoglobina tiene cuatro puntos que
permitirán que cuatro moléculas de
oxígeno se unan y así una vez que llega
nuestro oxígeno hasta acá va a esperar
encontrar alguna hemoglobina que tenga
un lugar libre una vez que se une a la
hemoglobina el glóbulo rojo va a llevar
ese oxígeno al resto del cuerpo donde
sea necesario ahora voy a hacer un poco
de espacio porque quiero mostrarles algo
interesante aquí que con suerte les
ayudará a entender un poco mejor el
viaje que hace la molécula de oxígeno
imaginemos algo como esto tenemos aquí
un lindo rectángulo voy a tratar de
dibujar ese mismo rectángulo a un lado
así que pongan atención a los colores
porque no voy a etiquetarlos de nuevo
para mantener todo sencillo y agradable
lo que vamos a hacer es imaginar que el
viaje del oxígeno comienza en la parte
superior de este cubo que estoy
dibujando más o menos así y tiene que
llegar al fondo de este cubo rectangular
en el fondo tenemos los glóbulos rojos y
la
obinna es la última capa aquí abajo en
la capa superior está el albiol o con el
gas así que voy a indicar esto también
esta sería la capa superior el oxígeno
tiene que atravesar todas estas capas
por ejemplo en esta capa azul está el
líquido que recubre el interior del
alvéolo y permítanme dibujar una
molécula de oxígeno que comienza su
viaje aquí que es la fase gaseosa cierto
por lo tanto tiene que salir de la etapa
gaseosa a través de la capa líquida
hacia la siguiente capa que es la célula
epitelial esa es la segunda capa la
tercera capa como dijimos es la membrana
basal vamos a repasar la una por una
supongo que esta es una buena forma de
repasar esto luego tenemos todo este
tejido conectivo una bonita y gruesa
capa de tejido conectivo que resalto en
color verde y recordemos que la membrana
basal y el tejido conectivo están
repletos de proteínas de diferentes
tipos de proteínas pero ambos están ahí
para dar soporte estructural aquí hay
más membrana basal en este lado y esto
va a ser justo antes de llegar a las
las endoteliales esa es la capa
endotelial esta es la célula que forma
las paredes capilares y luego tenemos
algo de plasma dijimos que el oxígeno
tiene que pasar por algo de plasma y
finalmente entra al glóbulo rojo la
razón por la que estoy dibujando esto
con todo detalle es que todo esto es
líquido y es predominantemente agua
recordemos que nuestros cuerpos están
compuestos en su mayor parte de agua
entonces nuestra molécula literalmente
pasa del gas que está en la parte
superior de nuestro cubo rectangular
todo el camino a través de muchas capas
diferentes de líquido sería más fácil
dividir esto en dos categorías gas y
líquido de hecho esto nos va a ayudar a
conectar con estas ecuaciones que hemos
estado aprendiendo
entonces permítanme escribir estas
ecuaciones que mencionamos antes y
veamos si podemos descubrir cómo se
relacionan con lo que estamos viendo
ahora si hay una relación clara sobre
cómo usar estas imágenes que he dibujado
aquí esta primera ecuación es la
ecuación de gas alveolar de la que hemos
hablado antes
también hay un vídeo sobre esto por si
quieren refrescar sus conocimientos la
primera parte de esta ecuación de gas
alveolar nos dice cuánto oxígeno entra
al alvéolo recordemos que esta capa
superior es el alvéolo esta de aquí
entonces nos indica cuánto oxígeno está
entrando a este alvéolos y esta segunda
parte indica cuánto oxígeno está
saliendo y si restamos lo que está
entrando menos lo que está saliendo el
residuo indica cuál es la presión
parcial del oxígeno en ese espacio
gaseoso a que equivale este peo 2 azul
esto de hecho nos lleva a nuestra
segunda ecuación tenemos esta segunda
ecuación que nos ayuda a determinar
cuánto oxígeno o cualquier molécula
realmente va a entrar o difundirse de
acuerdo con esta fórmula que es una ley
fija podemos resolverlo tomando algunos
parámetros podemos decir bueno si
sabemos que el gradiente p1 p2 es una
cierta cantidad y si conocemos el área y
el coeficiente de difusión y el grosor
entonces podemos encontrar v&v es la
cantidad de oxígeno
en este caso nos vamos a centrar en el
oxígeno la cantidad de oxígeno que se
difunde con el tiempo así que esto es
realmente muy útil porque si comenzamos
a notar que la cantidad de oxígeno que
se difunde con el tiempo y el suministro
de oxígeno que llega a los glóbulos
rojos es bajo entonces podríamos
preguntarnos a qué se debe esto y
recordemos la capa de glóbulos rojos que
está aquí abajo
esta es la capa de glóbulos rojos
entonces comenzamos a preguntarnos cómo
es que el oxígeno que está en el albiol
llega hasta los glóbulos rojos podemos
llamar a la presión parcial de oxígeno
en el alveolo p1 y podemos llamar a la
presión parcial de oxígeno aquí abajo en
los glóbulos rojos pedos y entonces
cuando calculamos mediante la ecuación
del gas alveolar esto básicamente nos
dice esto las dos ecuaciones están muy
relacionadas si notamos que la cantidad
de oxígeno que se difunde desde el
albiol o hacia la capa de glóbulos rojos
es menor o mayor de lo que esperábamos
tenemos que pensar bueno es el efe y o2
lo que pensamos que era
por lo general el aire ambiental es de
21% pero tal vez esta persona tiene un
40% o 50% porque le están poniendo una
mascarilla facial y está recibiendo
mucho más oxígeno del que hay en el
medio ambiente esta podría ser una razón
para tener un valor más alto también
puede obtener un valor más alto o más
bajo porque tal vez no estamos al nivel
del mar tal vez estamos trabajando con
un paciente a nivel de montaña o tal vez
por debajo del nivel del mar eso también
podría explicar una cantidad anormal de
oxígeno que se difunde con el tiempo y
estas dos cosas que dibujé en cajas
anaranjadas van a afectar a p 1
esta es la presión parcial inicial de
oxígeno en los alveolos algunas de estas
cosas tienen menor probabilidad de estar
cambiando y no esperaría que el cociente
respiratorio lo estuviera haciendo si la
persona tiene una dieta estable entonces
eso no debería ser diferente la presión
parcial del agua probablemente tampoco
esté cambiando especialmente si estamos
a temperatura corporal y la presión
parcial de dióxido de carbono si podría
pero para simplificar las cosas y si
solo estamos pensando en la oxigenación
vamos a suponer que probablemente esa
tampoco sea la razón así que revisando
la lista de verificación mental sabemos
que perú no va a hacer algo que queremos
considerar con mucho cuidado también
queremos considerar muy cuidadosamente
el área que pasa así es porque la
persona con la que estamos tratando
tiene muchos alveolos que ya no
funcionan
digamos que sólo la mitad de sus
alveolos están funcionando esto
significa que la mitad de su superficie
se ha ido así que realmente no está
obteniendo un intercambio de gases tan
efectivo porque la mitad de sus
superficies ya no está y sólo la mitad
de sus alveolos son capaces de hacer que
el oxígeno se difunda entonces es muy
importante considerar el área
superficial y su grosor y cuando digo
grosor me refiero a que el oxígeno tiene
que salir de esta capa de gas y recorrer
todo esto hacia abajo hasta llegar a la
capa de glóbulos rojos así que es un
camino muy largo que recorrer y si
agregamos un montón de líquido a esta
capa de aquí tal vez al tejido conectivo
hay más líquido en esas capas en
particular que son generalmente las
afectadas entonces eso aumentará el
grosor esta es una razón más por la cual
la cantidad de oxígeno que se difunde
con el tiempo puede estar lejos de lo
esperado y de nuevo aquí abajo no
esperaríamos que el coeficiente de
difusión fuera diferente de lo que
pensábamos porque el coeficiente de
difusión es bastante estable si sabemos
que estamos hablando de oxígeno dentro
del agua a cierta temperatura corporal
eso no va a cambiar mucho y finalmente
esta p 2 es la presión parcial de
oxígeno que está regresando del cuerpo
entonces si el cuerpo usa mucho oxígeno
y lo regresa cuál es el nivel de oxígeno
en la sangre que regresa y no esperamos
que eso cambie mucho porque el cuerpo
probablemente esté usando una cantidad
bastante constante de oxígeno así que no
vamos a suponer que esa es la razón así
que de nuevo si alguna vez se encuentran
con una cantidad anormal de oxígeno que
se difunde con el tiempo desde el albiol
o hasta la sangre entonces hay que
revisar esta lista de verificación y
pensar en estas fórmulas y en cómo nos
ayudan a ser muy
temáticos al pasar por cada una de estas
variables y pensar en cuál podría ser la
razón por la que la cantidad de oxígeno
que se difunde en el tiempo es mayor o
menor de lo que esperábamos